it's been confirmed by the UK Health
security agency that two poultry workers
working in England had been detected to
have bird flu rather was detected in
their systems now these people the
identities of them are unknown but what
we do know as you say is that they were
part of an asymptomatic testing program
which was taking place regularly at the
farm now they had been testing often
with their colleagues and this was for
people who had been in contact with
infected Birds now these two individuals
did not display any symptoms standard
symptoms being shortness of breath flu
and also a cough and they also have
since tested negative now an
investigation is currently underway into
how this has come about and in the
meantime precautionary three measures
have been put in place